this video is brought to you by liquid
IV more on them after the
reaction citizens of the reject Nation
it is time for Reacher season 2 episode
8 John 110 it up what's going on John I
am am excited for the
fin oh that's really well done I'm sure
you thought of that on the car ride over
ladies and gentlemen be sure to leave a
like on this video thank you to all have
been joining us thank you to prepper for
helping us edit down each one of the
highlights for this specific series and
thank you to all been joining us at our
patreon page is where you get the full
length Reaction watch along where you
sync up with your own copy of Reacher
available for super sexy rejects of
course and over there we cover several
things exclusively with highlights and
watch alongs included I'm ready to see
what happens here let's see what goes
on sounds like some liquid Terminator
Tunes actually the lighting here kind of
looks like Terminator yeah it's all blue
it's Sleek uhuh he's a good looking
[Music]
boy hands behind your back
Reacher he's like it looks better that
way what's wrong with me surveillance
photos don't do you justice you're going
to make a hell of a hole when you hit
the ground no no the hole in is season
3 Metal
Gear get him ready ready he's going to
perform for them you get beat up
yeah
clemon
no you weren't in charge no you're a sh
man damn hands behind his back and all
woo oh
boy come on
bud wow do something cool jump over your
bound hands or something oo
ow where is she the force of those kicks
there's only one body down at the
Corner's office and it ain't nearing now
where is she put the gun down we both
know you can't shoot me till you find
her yeah she's your last loose
end right I can't shoot no ow but he has
a family
now I don't want to leave anything for
ballistics dig that slug out of it we
got him right where we want him boss
ouch dude how many times were you up
against Brad Pitt in an
audition oh no oh no oh boy God you
don't mess with the 110 ah man special
investigator is going to get
you let's go
sneaking music Neely kneeling
hey it's like the shot of the Jack
Reacher
movie oh my
God the Precision I would love to play
Halo with you yeah I would love to
respawn frequently with you perimeter
guards neutralized what's your ETA 3
minutes out who I didn't catch it it's
going to be surprise maybe it's uh maybe
it's Ros his hand is
thumbnail let some time go by and then
quietly
retire definitely oh yeah definitely a
thumbnail then your boy Swan started
sniffing around brought his Pals in on
it and my wellth thought out plan like a
Time
Square ouch it looks like he did the
deal and took the money and ran and I
still end up with my toes in the sand
and a bronze ass on my lap oh thank God
he explained it oh but now that plan is
gone to [__] too cuz I got one of youing
[__] running around out there where
is she jeez this is most we've seen
reach for messed up Jack bleeder you
seem
upset
I offered to cut swan in where is he
yeah buddy six feet deep here you want
to see him oh my God they've reanimated
him they brainwashed him they made him
as a Deadpool machine from or yeah he
can't sing
anymore
oh see I didn't need all of it to frame
him this his fingerprint to get into the
computer sign off on some documents and
his Iris to scan when he logged in and
out of certain parts of the building
that's cruel in a pristine house it
looked like he took the money and ran
did you just carry it around in that jar
even leaving his poor dog behind Reacher
hates that oh now I really want Robert
Patrick to die did you teach him that is
this your
fault yes that's what he's been
grappling with little bit this reunion
is over I got a meeting with a man
that's going to give me $65 million load
those two on a chopper and then come
back for this [__] why can't they
load that [__] on right now yeah well
he's too heavy for one Chopper to carry
so they got to get a few so swan has
been helping them yeah he is guilty from
beyond the grave but maybe he's still
alive and they only just took that one
finger and that one
eyeball you came through the boy
sweet
paratroopers oh
boy get to the chopper
leave anything behind go flush this go
flush this awesome I may have some of my
guys go by and find ne's father pick him
up that i' to flush her out of the
woodwork what do you think I just really
really hate Loose Ends yeah dislocate
yourself or that yes yes the faceter the
faceter White
Rabbit but those kids back go run them
the hell out of here we don't want any
Witnesses when we leave go murder those
kids when she's 10 ft
tall here you go chasing
[Music]
rits I thought I told you kids to stay
the hell away from
here yeah strong middle
finger I'm telling you for the last
time get out of here before i k your ass
no it's NE yeah I'm just waiting for
Rosco to return I know post credit as
soon as you have them secure on that
copter go find out why that music is
still playing so that was the plan
distract them with the music
okay you're in here with me
yes yeah yeah that's right go NE boom
make America great
again
oh Reacher
uncuffed damn Jes
damn there's like one shot left in there
yeah over the shoulder cool love a cool
motion hey hey keep your head down and
stay over there stay
here you just don't mess with the 110
yeah got to save Swan's eye man this
guy's always out of
bullets oh boy the loose end the loose
end arrives hey this look this is
Terminator this is The Terminator cyber
D shootout
much jeers airplane or no Hendrick I'm a
swan Hendrick is
overrated next's getting
away but what about this showdown with
am going to take a few minutes to warm
up first go down right maybe am will
blow up the chopper how much ammo you
got not enough to cover your slow plan
on running out of here going to have to
make two I'm free am ammo
so much glass shattering in this episode
how many henches are
there Jack
Runner Jack jumper Jack
choer jump
Reacher wow dude you know if Tom Cruz
was Jack reach for still he'd really be
doing
that he really did this at full
altitude ladies first it's your turn
sweetheart he could use the wind to
ascend into the helicopter yes make
yourself
aerodynamic or
that yes it's raining
guns yes yeah that's what I'm talking
about man damn am OD Donald good call oh
man it's going to come full circle he'll
throw him at the
helicopter
oh well now what are you going to do
come damn whoa no no it's well stage
sequence wow ow
ah God damn it that this freaking guy
Jack really get it hurt you're an
overachiever man
[Music]
oh this is like a big action movie
finale Jesus Christ Rich you just don't
know what to hit him with the
stretcher you should be kicking Jack in
the balls
yeah
no no Jack she can use the wind to
Ascent yes right flip it up
get it you kick him
now owie I can use your Pal's brass
knuckles and smash your skull or you can
let the [__] fall and toss you out
after
yeah dude that was that was sweet yeah
that was sweet
wa everyone lives but on you better hold
this thing steady or we're going to find
out the hard way if I can land it yes
ma'am wait wait wait but you won't find
out cuz you'll be dead nice elbow no no
no no you you can still stop the missile
from getting in the hands of a terorist
they'll do it either way throw him
where's going to leave myve you assume
that's the information I need langon but
in an investigation assumptions killed
assumptions
coill yeah full
circle
oh dude that shot that was a really cool
line but I hope you actually know where
the hell am's headed you heard him say
that yeah right they're going to meet
one of the new age engineers at his home
so he can teach the buyers how to put
the Little Wing chips into the rockets
look I have the coordinates please just
don't kill me take us there land the
chopper right on top of the house
where's
a you know he's just fixing someone's
face up giving him some lip fillers
oh yeah we'll forever debate was he
right he starts repairing himself was
there a greater
sacrifice there he is the man of the
hour excellent Langston's already here
cuz that' be so fun to shoot this season
all that
snow yeah yeah yeah yeah
they finally meet must be some mistake I
don't know any of you people your little
scientist friends being held in the barn
with the pilot you killed our friends
prepare to die I I understand that
you're upset but I didn't kill your
friends I didn't even know them but I
know you you don't care how many people
die so long as you get your finder fee
arrest me and get it over with oh know
that's not how it works bet a guy like
you I we got a top-notch lawyer on speed
dial oh my God are they going to all
shoot at the same time yes tell us who
you're selling the weapons to oh I'm
sorry that would ruin my reputation and
my business not that I would expect any
of you to understand I can see that
you're
idealists between the seller of the gun
or the user I prefer to be the seller
the base mindset that a person has to
embrace to actually pull the trigger is
no better oh yeah all right everyone
unload I I wanted to hear his
speech oh yeah oh my
God my firing squad wowe you don't mess
with the special investigators we'll
forever Wonder was am right this whole
time was it just business M build up to
am was real uh antil climatic what do
you mean I mean that they kept building
him
up he's dead now we we did it what do
you want to do with these
two oh send them home in a body bag I
didn't kill anyone I only flew the
chopper I was just doing my job what's
your excuse I was just going to show
them how to implement the chips I had no
idea what they were all going to be used
for yeah right they can't have been for
something good get out of here both of
you in the snow they'll probably die
that's why he's letting them go the
illusion of
Freedom are they going let him use the
helicopter to fly off I guess so
unless they rigged it to blow like Place
Beyond Pines that
[__] oh they're going to blow it they're
going to use the missile
wow Jesus Christ oh and and if it's got
its Little Wing Chip it'll definitely
hit its Target just wait till they're
over the river that's that
rich wow what a boss cold I think we're
good Ney are in the
[Music]
hole it's so
mean wait for
it fly on Little
Wing you got to be [__] me sorry but
Senator Lavoy was clear oh yeah the
senator can't take the risk one of you
might talk I thought you might make a
move as soon as I let him get on the
chopper
me too maybe they just really wanted to
see me shoot those [__] down was
pretty cool was sick it was sick figured
Lavoy was the kind of guy that would
cover his ass that's why I didn't just
call theoy I also called Omar Kareem in
Homeland hey let's go Homeland boys are
coming back
yeah let me see your
hand cutting him pretty close is
government ever
efficient no it's
not
is it done is it over
[Music]
almost there's just one last loose end
that needs tying up I think this is
what's called a win-win you've got the
green
Lighty wow one more thing where's the
money what
[Music]
money you going to be in the nicest suit
next
season
you really should take that guy to the
hospital yep you should all go to the
hospital it really needs to go to the
hospital he's been shot stabbed
beaten the hosital moved unceremoniously
don't care how cool this looks he should
go to the hospital he's going to bleed
out in the
booth oh man there's so many possible
thumbnails here y
oh what can I get you coffee black black
Reacher serious
pops puffs of pees in that preference
neie doesn't have a scratch on her nope
she good what are we going to do with 65
million of moons got to use it to make
up for some of the pain it cost what
donate it to charity you care less about
money than anybody I've ever met right
sure you should be in charge of it
handle it big guy I think we should give
it to that person over there give it
all got 50 cents you have 65 million 3
Ines from you sh boxes don't take bar
bonds yeah what song what song though
what song Jack Frank Sinatra Strangers
in the Night I think it'll be a a snow
song uh D Martin Ain't That a Kick In
The
Head uh that's a
more oh my God possible
thumbnail yeah it's good idea it's a
good idea oh
a kind of forgot about her yeah it's
millions of dollars ear marked for my
kids it can't be for my
brother that'swe this is a touching ass
ending take care of the
spot card get to move on Wow J not
suspicious at all IRS going to be
breathing down the back of your Thro
that is a whip make sure you get the the
logo in there all right make sure we
know who made the car yes
I think at this point I'd be glad these
people are dead yes see it really worked
out for me [__] but I'm rich now yeah I
got an
Audi animal
shelter yes oh my God I love this what a
great Montage Mr I'm Connie bumy from
Chicago Home Health I'm part of the team
that's been hired to provide you round
the medical care that's great a I'm
going to sleep with this woman that's
the kind of medical care I want what did
you do you'd have felt funny if I just
put cash in your account it won't take
it away from your father I got him a
prostitute I tell you you're a good
friend
Reacher a not nearly enough nearly
enough hey would the world's scariest
Santa Claus put under my tree this year
I didn't give you a penny commitment I
put a shitload in your kids names Credit
Union around the corner from your house
wow you can quit yours I started a
Delaware LLC in your name fully funded
go hang your own shingle too smart to be
working for anyone but yourself yeah
wow wellow thank you thank you Jack
llcer what' you get for yourself I took
mine birded I need a new
toothbrush I bought 3,000 toothbrushes
they're all made of solid
Platinum when I found out that you were
wandering the Earth with nothing but
what you could carry in your pockets
thought you lost your mind but this show
is really cool there's a part of me that
thinks that you're the only one out of
us it's got it all figured out it ain't
perfect but it's a life can't believe
I'm going to say this but I actually
miss Swan's guitar playing right now you
could AI generate it to absent
friends it's absent friends spent 70
million making a hologram of swan we can
carry around anywhere with us we should
take another picture
yeah we
should guess you're not going to let me
just take this one either huh not a
chance boss print one out for him this
time oh there is a touching
ending NE don't touch Rocka away
[Music]
Beach a one more for the
road he's in Rosco's bed it was all a
dream oh grave I can't leave
Marve good you're awake I thought you'd
gone I did got you a present IB profen
it's in a sack Reacher and they're on
the sack Reacher that's your one it's
the one get yourself something with the
money wowe look at that there's
something else you can do name it come
home with me I really want you to meet
my parents wow
[Music]
damn I'm with you
should have seen your face but I see
what we've been doing these past few
days not so much as new business but old
business I have no unfinished business
old business they really needed to be
taken care
of before this meeting's adjourned I
think this particular item needs one
last going
over I second that motion I saw Donal
and I told him that I'd share with him
to the airport so I've only got him this
might take more than a minute oh give me
seconds that's not what odonald
[Laughter]
said love birds no attachments not as
comfortable with this Arrangement as I
thought I was years without seeing each
other never speaking getting together
only when we're being shot at need to
get better at staying in touch give him
a phone is that
understood Yes Master Sergeant you will
will be a series regular you refer to
these special investigators as your team
family soldiers your familys yeah do it
you know we're more than that right just
family come to the barbecue possible
thumbnail where you coming from right
here doing what visiting family hey he
said it he said what it was that she was
implying so where you heading no idea
now don't talk to me old man the
patience exercise on this guy
[Music]
woo they should have let the the credits
play over just the bus driving endlessly
all right reject Nation so today I want
to share something with you that has
been a wonderful addition to my health
and fitness journey that I discovered
during the holidays and that is liquid
IV's hydration multiplier I'm down to my
very last packet and I'm freaking out
but it's okay I got more in the man now
a lot of you have been so kind to notice
how I've been working on my physical
health thank you for all the compliments
and one thing I learned is that proper
hydration is absolutely crucial
especially post-workout and pre-filming
after post-workout and my wife actually
introduced me to this product which is
perfect because we not only care about
quality but a good taste and quality
product whether it's after a sweaty
workout or just after you know a good
night out you know what I'm saying
efficient hydration and replenishing
electrolytes is key you just feel better
and it tastes fantastic I can't
emphasize that enough and I'm always on
the lookout for too is products that
have zero sugar or zero sugar added
because that's one of my main dietary
restrictions throughout the week and
they of course got products that fit
that description that also tastes good
too so yes thank you so much so liquid
IV's hydration multiplier is in summary
is they are a non-GMO electrolyte drink
that delivers hydration into your
bloodstream faster and more efficient
than water alone cuz sometimes drinking
a whole gallon is not always efficient
but in fact it can provide the same
hydration is drinking two to three
bottles of water I'm also big on
efficiency plus it's packed with 11
essential vitamins and we know vitamins
are good for the body it's vegan soy
free gluten free and dairy free you can
customize the water amount to your taste
again perfect for post night recovery
traveling or just having a big night out
you know what I mean no so if you want
to booster support for the channel and
booster hydration game go to liquid
i.com and use promo code reject at
checkout that's liquid iv.com promo code
Rejects and remember liquid IV it's not
a real IV sure feels like
it so stay hydrated stay healthy and
let's keep crushing those health and
fitness goals together in the year 2024
all righty ladies and gentlemen uh I for
listen this on Apple or Spotify we just
watched Reacher
episode8 out of season 2 the finale for
it and I thought that it was a strong
close to this season I thought it was
really strong yeah I remember last
season people feeling a bit up and down
about the way how see I scw I want to
talk about last let talk about this this
season I thought uh ended they they
wrapped up everything well it was
exciting it was tense I thought the last
few minutes uh as they were wrapping up
with how they dispersed the money to
everyone the $65 million I really don't
know how you evenly disperse all that
that's so much money that's so much it's
like okay like I give this guy five
million I give this person five five 510
I still got like $30 million left to you
know
like everyone they cut around to him
like how much did everyone get exactly
the kids yeah there that's millions of
dollars but the the connection between
um the our Core group of the of the 110
special investigators uh the LA the last
episode in this one really let me feel
that Bond and that core unit between
them uh and and it ends on a note where
I would like to see them back I I I i'
very much enjoy that and I felt the uh
Melancholy goodbye that he was feeling
here you know like this really is his
family whereas in last season he was a
stranger wandered into town made some
connections this really was his family
and he's this the second time he's had
to say goodbye to them and I could feel
some it was kind of clenching in my
heart a little bit I felt I felt the uh
the uh bittersweetness of it all because
even though they get to have like
brighter Futures ahead of them due to
you know the financial gains and other
prospects that have occurred from it at
the same time yeah it's you you know
Reacher doing his Reacher thing and
reaching on to a new
city after explosive action just kept
getting caught up in how he could like
ride a bus and not have like a phone or
headphones or any of that just just like
the man can Master
non-stimulation whilst leading some of
the most stimulated
experiences I can never fathom being a
part of well it's like that thing they
say it's like you know and I'm sure you
you've experienced this as a person who
stopped eating added sugar is like you
know everything around you all the
Natural Foods become more flavorful when
you get used to that so maybe Reacher in
not indulging in various distractions is
just like getting the most juice out of
every single moment and scenario so
maybe on that bus you know he's
collecting people's stories he's hearing
the vibrations of the road and he's
seeing the motherland the Heartland I
should say in a in a good I don't know
that could be one of it that could be
but it is a it is a funny Trope of like
is he just sitting here staring out the
window the entire time or talking to
whatever old person wants to talk to him
there are some funny action cliches I
went down here like I I have a hard time
believing in this world I believe it but
when I step back and think about it
Homeland letting him use the missile on
the
helicopter
bit a little bit much there U what you
did and there are some storylines that I
thought could have paid off in a more
cathartic way the way with am how they
they were really building that up they
they really built it up and it seemed
like they were dividing their time
between buildup between Showdown with
Lon or Showdown with am and and am has
demonstrated himself to be the more
lethal ruthless calibrated one so it
seemed like oh this could be a real Foe
for him this could be someone who could
not just challenge him physically but
mentally you know they could read a real
cat and mouse game about it especially
with the amount of time they spent
separate from Langston and Reacher just
like he had his own show taking place
whenever we cut to him that I really
thought we were building to something
with him and I feel like the show was
intentionally doing that so I did feel
like while it's cool when they all like
shoot him uh I did feel a tad bit like
oh okay I guess I guess that's it and
because they were like divided time
between him and langon and Langston as
much as he was the guy in charge he
never felt as threatening as am did and
because of that I'm like yeah I wanted
linkston to die sure he did some messed
up things but he was kind of a one-note
character he wasn't as interesting of a
character as great of an actor as Robert
Patrick is he's one of our greats he
it's the the the character's very one
note very stock yeah he's a very stock
villain with the swear words he's always
like Angry you know he ain't [__] at the
end of the day yeah yeah so yeah you
want him to die but I for me I was at
least looking forward to a showdown with
am because with the amount of buildup
they were doing with it so that part a
little let down by and then the stuff
with the senator would have probably
felt a little more rewarding if that
wasn't if that was a little more flushed
out too so there there there was a lot
more pieces than last season so some
stuff while always hitting that cool
note yeah while it was always cool and
while the performers were always really
good and while you would get like action
and violence in certain moments that
were like sweet and while I felt the
emotions of the wrapup here probably
stronger than I did for season 1
honestly I still feel like H they kind
of missed the ball on a couple of things
here that I feel like could have been
stronger and you know there's other
narrative choices that we've already
been over and probably beaten to death
by this point when it comes to like
other things involving like building up
the 110 instead of just saying No Mess
with the 110 like really just getting
time with it blah blah blah there's
other things that we've uh really
touched on quite a bit uh but in terms
of this finale it was those those
shortcomings that don't make me dislike
the finale I just feel like there was a
stronger finale that probably could have
risen up and
outside of that though it is still like
very entertaining and I would really
like to see season 3 I'd still like to
see the 110 return M
and yeah that's about it
but yeah I mean John do you uh I left a
lot for you there I think I I'm pretty
sure pretty sure that are you going to
share your opinion not that happen in
this episode no I would agree I think
that yeah the the totality of this
season I'm sure after season one's major
success they probably had to look around
and go okay what do we maintain for this
and what do we tweak a little bit to
play to that much broader of an audience
and so I feel like this is a little bit
more down the rabbit hole of action
movie cliches than the first season not
in a again not in a bad way I've enjoyed
most all of it and yeah I do I yeah in
terms of the villain presence I feel
like they split the personality and the
physicality in half so it's like you
have Langston who's technically the like
shot Colin action taken guy whereas you
know am is very much like the O this is
an interesting presence and he's got
this demeanor and you know he's always
very calm and he's just snaking his way
across the country and uh and yeah
ultimately the impact of both of those
is a bit dampened by a the fact that
yeah Langston is just bad guy he's just
bad guy you know and it's a bummer that
they don't capitalize as much like
Robert Patrick is good but he's he's
this is the flavors of this character
are things he could do in his sleep and
then with am I appreciate maybe the
subversion of the idea that you're
working your way across the country and
you're like oh yeah these plots are
going to collide and it's going to be
something big and even the idea that
he's there being like no I'm just the
I'm just the money guy I'm not you know
I don't have the same philosophy like I
thought that was a sort of interesting
note that they started to play before
they you know killed him but uh yeah
like for the build of that mystery and
just the cool presence they heaped upon
him it does feel like oh that's like a
last minute thing we got to take care of
now by the end rather than like oh man
this major threat is about to get
wrapped up uh so yeah I think the first
the only thing I'll say between this
season and the first season is just that
this moves a bit more like an actual
action movie or something like that
whereas that first season moved more
like a like an atmospheric you know
regional thing that happened to have
action heavily involved in its
execution um so then you get to moments
like in the finale where they're hanging
out of a helicopter and Reacher holding
the stretcher and like I like that stuff
I think that's cool and it's relatively
plausible within this world but it is
pushing further into the realm of big
spectacle and things like that and then
you do have to rely on yeah the idea
that Homeland Security will let you use
this like you know corrupted piece of
technology that has like horrific real
world implications but just once cuz
you're the good guys you know which is
fine and and and that kind of reminds me
of a moment like the one in I think it
was the previous episode where they like
straight up murder that guy in the
hospital and like the the the ways in
which the philosophical aspects of the
show are maybe a little more fast and
loose this season because uh I feel like
effects like that last time around would
have been like very fleshed and very
like understood from an emotional and a
and a contextual standpoint whereas here
there is a little bit of Getting By on
like well they're well we trust Jack and
they're all just so badass yeah yeah you
know um but but this season still has
things that I'm going to be thinking
back on and remembering I mean
everything with Russo I really liked a
lot uh and that left an impact even
though his presence on screen maybe was
a bit shortlived and yeah like all the
members of the 110th I like in
retrospect thinking back and going oh
man like we had our suspicions and we
were worried that certain twists would
come along and no they they proved to be
the characters that you know the guy we
all trust said they were and and I I was
gratified to reach the end and not have
to do some thing where like a Dixon
turns around and is like ah you couldn't
just leave it alone could you you know
or something like that and uh yeah like
the the the places you meet these char
especially somebody like odonnell and
the kind of jokes and the and the you
know notes that they pin on each one to
give them their distinct flavor by the
end they all felt like yeah characters
bonded with history and also a new
chapter to that history that we all got
to witness so yeah I I still am like you
said really excited for the next season
this one had some adjustments that
didn't like hamper the experience for me
but that I did notice and I am curious
to see how they maybe smooth out moving
forward but
yeah all in all this is a pretty
straightforward finale but I definitely
was Satisfied by the end I was I felt
like uh you know had a had a nice you
know hearty action meal yeah yeah solid
stuff all around and overall a touching
conclusion to a season where you get the
I think they hit their beats perfect
when it came to neie and Reacher at the
very end of how they would have a
Sentimental moment in these two
characters specifically you know so I
really feel like they understood it and
there's something about Neely being at
the restaurant completely unscathed like
not a mark on her that just made me love
her like uh something about that
specific this girl just she's not
perfect she really tries hard and uh she
works her butt off and then just like
look at her at the end just she's just
cool cool as a cucumber right yeah know
I thought that was really fun uh yeah I
really like her a lot and I'm excited
I'm sure she'll be back between all the
other members but ladies and gentlemen
what do you think about this season do
you like it more than season one are you
excited for season three what pitfalls
do you think this came to what were your
favorite Parts be curious to know leave
it all in the comments below thank you
so much for being here and we will chat
with all you guys soon hopefully see you
for season 3 whenever the hell that
comes
[Music]
out